good afternoon everyone
it is indeed a great honor
to join this tribute to the towering
titan of public service
senator harry reid
wasn't it deeply moving for all of us to
hear lana and rory and leif and josh and
key speak so lovingly of their father
you his children along with his many
precious grandchildren his darling
great-grandchild
are his greatest pride but hearing you
speak about him shows us
what a source of strength you are to him
of course the love
and happiness he shared with his adoring
and beautiful wife landra
was a source of joy to all of us
who know them
all of us here today
are here personally to celebrate the
life of our dear friend harry
some of us including two presidents of
the united states the vice presidents
members of both the senate and house are
also also here officially
to salute a legendary statesman
i have the privilege as speaker of the
house to bring the sympathy of the house
of representatives where harry once
served chuck will say not as long as he
served in the senate but i do lay claim
to harry because that's where i first
met him
i wasn't in congress then but he was in
the house and he was running for the
united states senate
it was 1985 in time for the 86 election
george marcus is here who took up his
cause
in san francisco my husband paul is here
and harry was a high priority for us
in winning the senate
so i'm as speak of the house please to
join our distinguished majority leaders
danny hoyer our members
of the nevada delegation dina titus
steve horsford and susie lee
to bring greetings of all of our
colleagues
to some we are all viewed
as a great person
i have a great deal i want to say about
harry
but you know harry he was a man of few
words and he wanted everybody else to be
a person a few words
and again we'll go to the phone calls
because i
immodestly say that i probably got hung
up by the most by harry reid
two or three times a day
for 12 years that is official working
days sometime saturday and sunday but
anyway even if we had a really succinct
conversation harry subject this
problem this
timing this
even was that succinct you know
click
click so sometimes i even called her
back said harry i was singing your
praises i was thanking you for the great
job you did in the legislation and the
rest
i don't want to hear it click
i
i even said to him as when he was
announcing his retirement i want to have
a big dinner invite all of your friends
that you've served with in the past in
the house in the senate and the rest
i don't want to do it
but i want to sing you know for them to
sing your praising i don't want to do it
save the money feed the poor
harry reid
his modesty made him
unique you might say in politics
but his humility was rooted in his
strong values from a humble childhood
rising from searchlight to the spotlight
and becoming one of the most celebrated
and consequential senate leaders in
history
yet throughout his more than four
decades of public service and even at
the highest levels he never forgot his
north star to fight for working families
like his own
and to fight for nevada
indeed harry loved his home state you
know that
he did everything he could to ensure
nevadan's voices were hurt
whether protecting the state's natural
environment
or its political environment especially
its coveted role in the presidential
selection process
to observe harry lead and legislate was
to see a master at work
fearless strategic knowledgeable and
brilliant
you know he was a pioneer
he fought like a pioneer
as harry as senate leader few could
rival harry's understanding of his
senators their states their needs their
ambitions
and in all of our conversations
before he hung up
i never heard harry say an unkind word
about any of his senate colleagues
democratic or republican
for the 12 years we served together as
leaders in our respected houses
i had the privilege of seeing his
mastery first hand rescuing american
families with the american recovery and
reinvestment act protecting hard-working
consumers with the dodd-frank reforms
and championing the passage of the
affordable care act just to name a few
under the leadership of president barack
obama and vice president joe biden
when he retired and we would no longer
be speaking constantly on the phone he
came to my office this was when he
announced his retirement he said nancy i
have something for you to remember made
by
i thought it might be a handwritten note
or special photo
instead he unveiled a massive
bald eagle
stuffed
but the wings sit still capable of
fluttering in the breeze
shocked i said harry
did you go hunting and killing
endangered species
he said no
he died flying into a power line and i
called him sparky
whether symbolic of his patriotism with
the bald eagle
his environmentalism or his dry sense of
humor and dry it was it is one of the
finest and most curious gifts i've ever
received
and the subject of great question in the
speaker's office
today this majestic bird has flown from
the senate leader's office over to the
speaker's office appropriately and with
his permission
now called
harry
for his great legislative achievements
his most enduring public legacy will be
that he was beloved
a word not often used to describe
political leaders
he was beloved by his colleagues by his
staff by maintenance workers and by the
capitol police and as the leader
mentioned with whom he served as a young
man as a capitol policeman
truly beloved by all
because he treated everyone with dignity
and respect
next week leaders schumer and i will
have the solemn privilege
of welcoming harry back to the capitol
to lion state
a proper tribute for an historic
patriotic american
may it be a comfort to landra and
beautiful family all who love him that
so many americans mourn with you
at this sad time paul and i who love
landr who loves london and loves harry
send you our personal sympathy and love
god truly blessed america with the life
and legacy of harry reid
may he rest in peace